[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm red and I'm
link joining us today at the roundtable
of dim lighting is us that's right it's
another red leaked only ear biscuit
y'all okay well I'm excited I'm excited
about this one not just because we get
to make another red link only your
biscuit link I always enjoy this we
don't have to accommodate anybody else's
schedule and get anybody water and we
just get to talk to each other cuz
getting people water is so awful I'm
joking I enjoy talking to other people
but you know every once in a while we
needed we need to root the long breeze
refresh our friendship with each other
this is about does this refresh our
friendship yeah I think so I think it
will today but are you wearing deodorant
actually I did smell myself a little
earlier and it wasn't good I'm just
honestly saying but you're on the
opposite end of the table I didn't feel
great about it I was like you know when
you have those moments when you smell
yourself and you're like if someone else
were to smell this would they know that
it wasn't human
well it was me human yeah speaking of
odd smells from humans we're gonna be
talking all about Walmart yesterday
Walmart you got to understand what kind
of special place Walmart holds in the
hearts of anyone who's from the southern
United States of America because I'm not
exaggerating that I would venture to say
that more than 50% of people in the
South spend more than 50% of their
income at Walmart did you think that's
an exaggeration well I know for me when
it was true of me I lived in North
Carolina that was true of me cuz you got
cuz you went to the Super Walmart you
got all your we got all our groceries
there there was no I mean when it's the
time that I was in Fuquay Varina there
was a Harris Teeter that had expensive
groceries or what we thought and you had
Walmart that had the cheap stuff and you
could get pretty much whatever you
wanted their target didn't have
groceries okay any time you needed any
kind of tool or anything it's like and
you're already in Super Walmart right
but now living in LA there's no access
to once there's one way way way way away
from my house and I went there one time
and it was Shady
it was a shady experience it was nothing
like the experience back in fuqua so
there's gonna be a reminiscing aspect to
this episode which is Walmart themed but
Morris
typically just like our recent red link
only ear biscuits which have been like
extended GMM styles we talked about
strange science experiments strange
rites of passage you can go back listen
to that if you want to either one of
those but this one hits a little closer
to home because it's weird things that
have happened documented things that are
weird that have happened within a
Walmart and you gotta understand we're
gonna be talking about some things that
have happened to us personally at a
Walmart I've got some more stories and
some things that happened to persons who
are not us because Walmart has had so
many people go in and out of its doors
it's automatically opening doors that
some of those people think that can has
our thing anything that can happen has
probably happened in a Walmart and then
been documented on the internet for us
to do research on right so that's what
it to you that's what you got in store
for you in this Walmart bizarre
happening ear biscuit but first we
wanted to remind you all about our song
biscuits volume one album featuring 15
of the songs that we wrote collaborated
with a lot of our friends from the
internet to create some songs based on
suggestions from the internet you saw
him on good mythical morning they were
every Saturday for 15 weeks and now you
can get it on iTunes and Amazon exactly
music yes Amazon the way you can get the
music featuring songs that's on Amazon
it is light it's also on iTunes which I
already said featured songs like the
five nights at Freddy's song featuring
markiplier the 10-second rule song
featuring nicepeter and one of our
personal favorites the first comet song
featuring us scream
and a new video pops up in your feed you
know exactly what this means open it up
but don't watch it scroll down really
quick can't comment you tie first you're
the first to comment on this video
now everybody knows that's the word you
chose you type first I don't know if
that's our personal favorite but one of
our personal favorites because it's just
us I mean that sounded a little selfish
but it's just one that turned out really
nice yeah I mean there's 15 so get them
all you know buy the album's it's a
special price guys $8.99 I mean where
else can you do that link where else can
you do that or do that have you found a
place you can do that probably other
albums on iTunes and Amazon but great
great they're not ours great way to you
know give some good music in your
library and show your mythicality thanks
for checking it out now let's continue
this biscuit let's enter the Walmart you
we parked a car we had to park kind of
far away but we're walking big old space
well what it was a big space could have
fitted like a dually in there yeah it's
like you can you be parked in the space
and you can open your doors all the way
now the reason why we're starting all
the way back here is because this is
like the first thing that we don't have
in LA is spaces where you can like open
your car door all the way my kids
usually get out of a minivan I'm just
gonna be real with you yeah and the way
a mini van door opens in the back it
just opens a little and then slides and
then the kids just get out but when I
think the kid works well when I take the
kids in the car with me they get out of
the backseat anywhere we park and it's
like I got to get out first in like spot
the doors because they just fling them
open and you can't fling a car door open
in lausanne you can because there are no
spaces you can no spaces that are big
enough to park a normal sized vehicle in
next to and with the doors less people I
mean if you have like a doorless car
with kids in it shame on you first of
all but second of all you got to stand
there if they got doors and you got to
like you got to spot it before it even
gets to the first notch well we're
really getting into this whole parking
space thing yeah we're not even in the
Walmart along but okay but here here's
the deal
not only there's just it was such a part
of our experience growing up and after
we grew up that one of the first songs
that we have a wrote that was
a comedy song was the Walmart song and
it was all about just a trip to Walmart
and we you know we performed it live
before we ever made a video for and we
actually never made a music video for
the Walmart saw the Facebook song was
written after the Walmart so Walmart
song was one of the very very first
songs that had you playing the harmonica
in it and it was all about a trip to
Walmart but we should play I don't I'm
not gonna say we're gonna play the whole
song for him
I'll let Kevin decide how much of this
song he's willing to share with you guys
but here's at least a clip of it
[Music]
[Music]
Gatorade don't play your hey if
pharmaceuticals gotta get beautiful I'll
pick up a little tool for pushing back
my cuticles I'm doing the phone to
continue to press song to little section
to try some s all the suggestions coming
from the loudspeakers end of the sale on
them fell crow sneakers
[Music]
so as you can see we got a lot of
mileage out of all the things that could
happen in a Walmart that you could put
into a song and I also wonder if you can
hear like how differently we sound and I
just been so long ago that was like 2005
when we probably recorded that song
maybe 2000 maybe earlier than that maybe
maybe 2003 no you're - you're still no
when we record it when we wrote that
song recorded that version of it it was
2002 2003 and I don't you know and now
hold on it's on just mail us the Grammy
is it don't just mails the Grammy I
believe the date I'll just mail us the
Grammy
might be 2001 I don't know it's it's old
okay oh don't worry is on it so that's
weird it's a backhanded apology but
let's get into some weird Walmart
stories that don't involve us just like
playing our own music or talking about
car doors opening okay we're gonna start
with one that does not involve us
personally and then we'll come back to
the personal ones okay okay this one
happens in Virginia just north of North
Carolina April 2011 18 year-old man
Jonathan Payton waltzes in to a Walmart
but not in a normal way okay he comes in
on all fours okay wearing a cow suit oh
well that makes sense then I mean if
you're mmm if you're if you're
moonlighting as a cow then you got to
come in on all fours
you know you that's like in the manual
of like the cow suit you guess you tell
me link what section of the store did
the cow command go to what do you think
you went what do you think you want to
go the cow dating section cuz Walmart's
have everything no he went to the dairy
section link the cow Jonathan goes on
all fours to the dairy section I don't
know exactly how he did this but he gets
26 gallons of milk 26 gallons of milk
now I don't know if there was a cart
involved but it made it seem like you
I don't know how you push a cart a while
on all fours like it would your head
okay maybe that's what he did he's
lodged his head underneath there it was
like a bull oh yes yes
after loading 26 gallons of milk into a
cart so he was on all fours got the cart
I guess he's pushing it with his head he
took pigs I guess how many hey you tell
me where's many gallons of milk can you
fit into a shopping cart uh
approximately 26 yeah yeah 26 you might
have you might have used the bottom part
maybe the bottom cart yeah that's a lot
of milk yeah I'd say that's it's $92
worth it that's what you were oh yeah
that's here in the store I was gonna do
some milk math that's $92 worth at the
time and okay yeah so he's looking for
like a discount right he's like Oh cute
oh yeah yeah the cows loading up ma no
no he he bypasses the checkout line goes
straight out the door of course because
he's inconspicuous right what he just
walks right out the new arms right out
the door but then you might wonder oh
okay so this on all fours pushing 26
gallons of milk just can walk right out
of a Walmart
you might think okay well okay I get it
he's he's he works here he's no he's a
thief and he's stealing it no no that
wasn't you know what was really
happening I mean technically yes he did
steal it but he when he got into the
parking lot what did he proceeded to do
he proceeded to hand out the gallons of
milk to customers in the parking lot
like a free giveaway yeah like people
walking into Walmart hey they gotta go
as a cow here today all the cows the cow
giving free milk at the Walmart it's
it's interesting if the customers
walking in then it was then they would
be liable to have to pay for it when
they left which is a funny thing you
know I get maybe it was giving it to
exiting customers but I would I would
assume does it as a customer I get there
they're trying to you know to hawk all
kind of where is outside of the Walmart
right home it's like a sample station oh
look it's a sample station but the
sample is a whole gallon what was his
motive I you know what link I don't know
if motives and Jonathan Payton
go together yeah maybe what was missing
you know what was missing that didn't
construct him I could have been Adair I
don't know but this is what happened you
know the reason we know that it was
Jonathan Payton is because he was caught
and the reason he was caught is because
he wore the the cow costume that leaves
your face open you can still tell that
it's Jonathan okay you can see Jonathan
on the security camera
he was very easily identifiable by
police that's Jonathan he was spotted
out of costume guess we're at a nearby
McDonald's and so he he went to the
number one place most people spend their
money and and then he went to the number
two place that people spend their money
he was found in me-dasu so he wasn't
still in the cow costume like giving out
burgers out front because that would
have also paid said well you know he was
out of the cow costume and the cow
costume was still in his car and he was
canned all the milk he was given a
summon and when he had given away the
milk I guess they let those people take
it he was given a summons and then
released from the scene and I assume
later he went to court who knows what in
court I mean I don't mean quar tea I
mean cor tea
it's just you know I would love to meet
this guy well I guess probably be
arranged Virginia he was 18 in 2011 you
know just as simple why yeah he's right
which let's have him on the show
let's put that money or biscuit what
were you thinking Jonathan Jonathan oh
no you're listening give us a call I got
another one March 2009 a Walmart in
Massachusetts specifically foul-mouth
Massachusetts this is the top is that
you say that fal mouth foul mouth I like
foul mouth fine you got a foul mouth
bullemma wash it out with soap once I go
into Walmart and get you get some or get
a 24 pack of zest what you mail that
what so strong so the Cape Cod Times
brought this story to me I can really
sink my teeth into it that's a pun once
you go with me a little bit a dude who
we don't have his name was shopping for
a new wallet at the foul-mouth
Massachusetts Walmer I'm gonna go with
Falmouth Palmas and just before
purchasing the wallet well you know what
did he do he uh you know he opened check
this thing out he opened up the billfold
he's like unzipping compartments I wrote
it so it's got a zipper compartment on
it that's really that's high-end for
Walmart I'm just gonna give me I'm gonna
give me some thought to buying this one
and lo and behold in one of the
containers within said billfold he finds
ten human teeth ten not one not two not
three not four not five not six not
seven nine eight not nine ten human
teeth one of which had a filling Oh
score yeah yeah was it a gold filling
because I take that out pocket it and I
don't think they do the gold do you
think I I do not have that information
with the Cape Cod Times
um please said the man was shopping at
the wall around around 10 p.m. when he
unzipped one of the compartments and
discovered 10 human teeth one with a
filling that's a good time to be a
Walmart yeah you know like a 10:00 p.m.
wallet shop that's I just you know you
go in there last time I went home to
North Carolina I went into the Walmart
about I'm not kidding about 10:00 p.m.
in it's the end of a decent evening no
one was there I was just like what how
does this happen
really nobody I've never been in a
Walmart with nobody like there was like
six people in the whole place well you
did you go to the wallet section no I
didn't well that's where they all were
but I mean it's just there's nobody
there and can I can i for a minute just
talk about wal wallet shopping in
general yeah I would love for you to do
um I always have had a problem with
wallet shopping life imitating I have
needed a wallet for a while yeah I've
only had like three wallets in my entire
life I'm not exaggerating because how
long you been on this one every this one
at least eight years let me see it it's
it it's it's actually the insert that
goes inside of a wallet it has no flap
and I had a I bought a wallet and this
was the
insert that holds your cards and that's
all I keep but anyway you got you know
you said I need to get a wallet or like
my mom and my wife will say you need a
new one new wallet I'm gonna get you out
don't get me a wallet and then I go and
I look at wallets and then it's like why
would I pay money to buy something to
put money it just doesn't seem right to
protect it say why spin spend money to
buy something to hold money and then I
don't have money to be held in the thing
that I just bought well you get more
money it's like it defeats the purpose
it's like man it's instant regret
I just spent do I need to say it again I
just spent them I mean the largest thing
the logic doesn't is not sound of me but
you know if it works for you
but if there were ten teeth in and one
of them had a feeling I would be like
yes that this is now worth at least have
a story right someone's gonna talk about
five years later the wallet still had
tags on it the guy is not like someone
put them wallet in there and it was used
this is a Brent someone walked in there
and put teeth it and put teeth in it you
think you know what they perform DNA
test oh yeah I'm sorry there was no
blood or gum tissue on the teeth right
so they could not get a DNA sample so
that's that is a piece of evidence it
was a tooth fairy what maybe one person
who walks around with just random teeth
and then that exists that that might
because the tooth fairy's not on my lip
might be in the Walmart two to three is
in the Walmart and he's like oh crap he
she's she I'm well the tooth fairy could
be a man there's many of them there were
that this ones man okay and he's in the
Walmart and I played the tooth fairy at
one point true you know in a video I'm a
man oh I thought you meant in real life
and he's he's you know he sees somebody
somebody spying him looking you know I
think I spotted the two-threes I gotta
unload these teeth nearest place is this
wallet I'm checking out right now well
put him in there well before I knew it
there was no blood or gum tissue the
first thing I pictured was some dude
shopping for a wallet who just decides
to pull out ten of his teeth
is that my yeah I got to get I got to do
some dental work right here go
on one yeah got nine more to go buddy
yeah yeah I'm going all away
actually that's esteem my father-in-law
is a dentist you know and he had a guy
show up at his house one night and a guy
had pulled all of his own teeth but he
got he got he said doctor doctor Lane
I've been pulling he taught us rajesh
dr. Lane I've been pulling all my teeth
all night and I got to my teeth and I
can't get him and if you're from the
South you know that I teeth means
canines this point he went appointee one
so he got to it
I tied here cookin got running the
indictment hangovers you know you can
get my own pink hair and so he took him
to his office he pulled his eye teeth
out
maybe that guy as if devoting a whole
hour to talking about Walmart wasn't
enough you just did a spot-on impression
of people who actually exist that if
you've never been in the South you
wouldn't believe that people actually oh
yeah even if they haven't just pulled
out all of their teeth why why was he
pulling on it because he knew they were
bad but I bet this this is probably your
insight I don't you going back on my
theory
I don't think it was a tooth fairy it
was that it was a guy performing oral
surgery on himself in Walmart he's like
man I got a doctor in here there's no
gonna trust in here I might as well just
do T surgery almost you and was he
hoping it wasn't employee he was hoping
to get like workers comp or something I
did their surgery and the dadgum Walmart
I was on homie but but with no blood or
gum tissue I keep having to tell you
they must have been in there for like
month this is somebody's saving teeth I
think it was a kid who had some teeth no
I'm gonna put them in no it was a guy
who did it
but then he put it in the wallet in
every back and no one found no one
looked through that wallet for like six
months until it all dried out was or
what it was a wallet and nobody wanted a
Walmart spokeswoman Ashley Hardy is
quoted as stations like somebody I would
have dated in high school we are not
aware of anything like this happening in
the past and we believe this to be an
isolated incident I love the fact that
the Walmart spokeswoman was trying to
head off the conclusion that everyone
was coming to about Walmart like
stuffing teeth in wall
everywhere all Walmart wallets have been
compromised I am never going to get
because you know what happens there
people go in there they pull out ten of
their teeth and then they throw it in
the wallets
well boycott Walmart I'll tell you
speaking of girlfriends in Walmart that
is one of my stories I might as well go
ahead and tell it lay it on me
I've told you you know this story I
heard it the next day because uh yeah I
mean this one happened in the past like
six or seven years this was my second
girlfriend because it hinges on the fact
that if you if you go to Walmart you're
gonna run into somebody you're gonna run
into somebody you gotta read to the
people that live in that town because
everybody goes you know it you know it
you go in there and you you got it you
got to get you makeup right you gotta
get your hair right-oh you can't be
wearing like those sweatpants that you
don't you know you got it like oh I
gotta get some Jolly Ranchers and then
yes I got to put on britches your whole
town reputation keep I can't keep my
holy shorts on hinges on what you look
like in the Walmart I gotta put on
underwear under these pants and when I
put on underwear I might as well put on
good britches and then you got it along
yeah I had a good good britches on and
this is my second girlfriend first kiss
also your second girlfriend first kiss
bingo yeah amber and you know we dated
in middle school and we dated again in
high school but we did not speak not we
weren't on bad terms it's just really
kind of lost touch didn't speak during
college and then there were you know
there's a number of years I you know I
get married all the children and I will
say there were a number of high school
friends within that close-knit group
that we did keep in touch with we talked
about on sorted food yeah a little bit
that we kept in touch with for many
years we didn't really but she wasn't
wanted no she wasn't she kind of went
off and did her own thing a little bit
you know and which made it a little
mysterious right yeah and I honestly I
hadn't done any I don't even know well
on Facebook at the time I surely I was
but but I wasn't I didn't stalk her on
Facebook or anything I had
kept up with her at all but you know
when you date somebody in that formative
period in your life do you never forget
them right your first kiss your first
like real relationship and it was a
middle school and it was in high school
there's always this this this you never
forget that sentimental mystique and so
it was crazy because you know I'm like a
25 year old dude maybe older than that
you know you know you're man you're
married I'm married you have a child and
I'm pushing a cart through the Walmart
and I'm and I'm going down I'm doing one
of those things where I'm going down the
I'm going along the aisles looking down
the aisles to get to the aisle that I
want to be in mmm and so I'm looking
down the aisle and I'm go but one I'll
go about two hours go by three aisles
and I look all the way down and I see
that she amber is on the opposite aisle
doing the same thing that I'm doing
going the opposite direction but we lock
eyes for real we'd lock eyes and you
immediately knew it with her after she
immediately knew was me I mean you're
you're you're tall and immediately yeah
and hair standing up on your head I'm
mistaken and we lock eyes how did you
know it was her she hadn't changed she
hadn't changed much no she did not
and we lock eyes and like two strangers
passing in the night
I keep going she keeps going you didn't
stop the car didn't start the car she
didn't stop the cart but the eyes lie
for a second
I mean you know what I mean like hip-hop
may have slowed down the car I all I
know is there was a weird guy lock and
there was a moment in which each one of
us could have just been like hey we used
to date but we don't have to talk about
that we can just say hi cuz we both have
we're both married and have kids and
doesn't have to be weird yeah yeah but
no sure and then I mean I was like oh
crap and then now once that happens the
Walmarts a big place but you're like she
was going this way I was going this way
I mean sooner or later we're gonna run
into each other again we're gonna born
unto each other at the checkout line
what should I do
so I just kind of went back to like the
meat section
for a while what I just kind of held I
kind of just laid low for you were
treated to the walk it's been a lot of
time in the meat section just perusing
dude mm-hmm but could but but you could
have played it like it was her who
didn't stop and then but you didn't want
to chase her right
hey I felt like after that initial look
it was I'd blown it it was but showed it
so did she
yeah I don't know something why's it got
to be all on you I don't know it was
like do or down to Walmart and that was
the man I should have been reflective I
should have been the one but I didn't
and here we are we still have not spoken
but what since that that's the last time
you like ten years ago
and it's not like what if you had to do
it again what would you have done I mean
it's not I would have just gone up and
said hello it wasn't weird I mean we
dated in high school
right but I made it weird you made it
she also made it we met together yeah he
was like old times yeah yeah you know
easily one of it it was like that
awkward first kiss
you're like it was like we just broke on
left am I going right well I'm going
right and you're gonna leave was like we
just broken up last week you know it was
like that level of like sorry dude but
I'm just gonna say that I think that
that's telling like telling what I don't
know it's there's there's revealing
there's something there that's I mean
that's what everybody who's listening is
thinking right now well this has been 10
years ago link another 10 years if I saw
her in Walmart now without a doubt I
would I would go talk to her
yeah no big deal I bet if you just go
back to that Walmart she'll be there
within three days yeah she just hang out
there he still lives in the area
yeah just go there for three days and
she oh I hang out in the meat section
she'd probably show up there too right
right why would hang out at the entrance
matter of fact just get a job as the
greeter
yeah just greet can I be a volunteer
greeter for threads a gratis x-ray Oh
from me
you might be walking in here it's like
it's like it's like the like the
real-life version of classmates.com
which by the way I've got a resurgence
of emails from those people yesterday
whoa you need to change your sizes I
know this this podcast is getting really
loose and going off the rails but it's
all still happening in Walmart can I
talk about classmates.com okay it's
subscribed again like I own just
subscribe like five years ago
yeah they keep coming back they keep
getting it they they do not heed a nun
subscription how did I even get on
classmates comm you know why cuz you
told me that story about amber six years
ago and I was like well I'm gonna get on
classmates comm I bet I can drum up some
people that way okay well you know let's
move on to a woman go to class be calm
slash rhettandlink you get $100 off your
nothin
we're not having anything to do with
them that let's uh let's move on to
Kingsport Tennessee there's a Walmart
there this is October 8th 2013
I remember it like it was yesterday what
day of the week was that do you know do
you have that that was a Thursday there
are people who have that ability there's
a dude that got hit in the head with
like a baseball bat with a calendar been
hit in the head with a baseball bat and
now if you say October 8 2013 he's like
Thursday you know you could say you
could even say like October 7th 1887
he'd be like Friday I bet he doesn't
tell anybody this story because it would
promote getting hit in the head with a
baseball right well this this is a woman
an older lady who when is that a nice
way to say an old lady an old lady okay
goes into the Walmart she's riding
around on a motorized scooter you know
one of those a motorized scooter mm-hmm
and he's killing it in there she somehow
gets a large flat-screen TV onto the
scooter
and then scoots for right on out the
front door and steals it Kingsport
police information officer she scoots of
a flat-screen television out the front
of the Walmart what's she wearing a
calcine right no she has no Cal suit
hazard was reported but Kingsport police
information officer yes there is an
information officer his name is Tom
Paton he does not carry a gun he just
carries knowledge he said weapon is
knowledge he said she was pulling it
behind her motorized scooter in her
shopping buggy right out the front door
oh she was towing it yeah it was towing
a heart yeah now that I know the
specifics it wasn't like power lifting
at a flat-screen but he says he
suspected that somebody had helped her
get the flatscreen into the buggy
because I mean he is some woman on a
motorized scooter can't lift that car
and can you also bungee cord it yeah
right exactly and that patent also said
I guess she was taking advantage of the
fact that she was older riding a scooter
and probably looked a little more
innocent don't miracle shoplifter to
help her commit her crime the
information officer gone ageist on this
making it about being an old man he's
probably right well and here's this
kicker link
she was never caught she was caught on
surveillance footage fast that's good
nobody recognized her and so like a
hyperspeed on it was 2013 this woman's
watching this television right now no
she's not she's still scooting no I
believe she settled at home yeah Wow
she's probably done this many times
she's like listen I got this little
thing I do they never get me so you like
walk in her living room and there's like
four flat screens she looks like a
security booth officer I think she
steals other things not just TVs I'm
saying I wonder if she kept the car too
well that's the thing about the cart
because it seems like it was one of the
carts that you can go and get in if you
need it and the thing I've noticed is
that you know you've got people who have
a just
who use that you got people who are
older and need help walking around when
I'm using my pelvis you used one in the
grocery store and that was legitimate
I remember you using the scooter in the
in the grocery store I remember because
I remember walking in we were like going
in there wasn't a Ralph's they didn't
have those back home it was uh what was
that cheap grocery store like IgA know
like Wiggly near the Food Lion Food Lion
I'm good I can make my cake keep going
that's it walk in the food line I'm on
crutches because I broke my pelvis and
I'm about to just follow you around the
Food Lion and then I look over to my
right listen
I can legitimately use one without
feeling guilty without feeling good I'm
like a lot of the teeny I see the
teenagers those teenagers go into the
into the stores like teeny and they get
on those carts and they and and they're
just doing it for fun lateen to these
days keep the buttocks out we'll just do
the automatic cart really have you seen
it I've seen it multiple times and I've
thought about saying something about it
but I was like I'm not that old yet I
got to have like a half a head of gray
hair before I can start yelling it
that's for using motorized scooters in a
Walmart so what do you do you're you're
like hopper Ross my arms and grunt
really hey I don't like to see people
take advantage of the system in you you
were a different story you had a broken
pelvis it's another story that was told
once on the Internet I would totally
confront wayward teens using scooter
devices in a in a public purchasing
environment I did once though steal
something from a Walmart maybe I should
tell that story I have told this story
because the elderly woman's story's over
she got away she got away and I got away
I'm sitting right here no one ever
charged me for this why did you bad
don't believe you know you be the judge
I've told this story I don't know
somewhere before
good mythical morning something like in
a confession booth you're not Catholic
I stole a battery or like a pack of
batteries but here's the weird part I
put I took another pack of batteries in
and put them in the Walmart and
and stole some out of the Walmart what
kind of exchange yeah but I didn't a
roguish okay so you're saying it wasn't
stealing are you but okay so give me
context you bought you legitimately
bought batteries from the Walmart I'm
saying I went to the Walmart I got one
of a one of a lot of different things
you know like what you do when you go to
the Super Walmart and one of the things
I got was batteries I get home I
realized I got the wrong size like see
instead of D but it wasn't yeah it
wasn't like a triple a double a mix-up
because that means that's just extra
batteries it was definitely like a C or
D mix-ups I don't need these
I needed this you know no battery you
won't eventually need it was a weird
situation in which it was some kind of
specialty battery that's all I'm gonna
say I can't remember the specifics okay
but then I'm like okay well I was taking
my daily trip to Walmart because I
literally went almost once a day I'm
sure and I was like I got these
batteries I need to exchange them I'm
gonna go buy you're talking to a Walmart
employee right now I'm talking to my I'm
setting the story okay I had batteries
and I wanted to exchange them and no
intention of stealing I put them in my
pocket to take into the Walmart with
your receipt maybe maybe not they don't
they don't require situm requires who
cares
I go in there I'm doing some shopping
and I'm like you know I got these
batteries I'm here I am in the battery
section I need these other batteries
they're the same price they're the same
price yep so I take how do you know you
don't have to receive I remembered the
records they're next to each other still
there the other ones still there okay
I pulled the batteries out of my pocket
I put them all back I look left and
right
did you look you look left and right
before pulling around you probably like
left right and left again like cars on
the street I mean every left if you look
left right and you're yeah it's a clear
sight that you're doing something wrong
if you look left right and left again
then you're guilty I mean I did look
left right and left again that's the
fact that you feel guilty that doesn't
mean you are guilty I took him out of my
pocket I put them on the rack and
the other was backing my brother pocket
pocket I'm sold the same pocket DMC
pocket and I kept shopping and I did it
and I just I don't know why it's so
stupid
did you think a diversion first because
the you thinking because I'm gonna throw
a like i'ma throw some batteries down
here where everyone's gonna look and
then while they're looking I'm gonna
walk about it just wasn't worth it if
you think about it it's so easy to
exchange things at a Walmart but I was
like I want to deal with that you know
about how embarrassing it would have
been to be caught for shoplifting like
and I was still I was a father at this
time yeah you and you know what you the
cops would have come up they would have
listed officer it's not really stealing
I was exchanging and it's the same price
and as you're pleading your case as
they're you're handcuffed and they're
walking you out of the Walmart you look
down the aisle and there at the end
frozen in a stair his amber yeah she saw
the whole thing
watch the whole thing she'd been there
waiting for you right oh gosh yeah you
know it's it's funny you didn't think
about anything except the fact that who
cares I just need to get a you know me
man I a steal I don't I just I don't
take a lot of risks and I know I got it
I'm really surprised i this is totally a
link moon that's like I've got another
stupid thing I do I'll tell you later
I've done a couple of stupid things when
I've been in a Walmart but it reminds me
here's a lot more makes me stupid here's
the thing that that's what I'm learning
put that on a teacher and then let them
sell it in a Walmart oh they do that's
irony and that can be on the tag that's
already it made me think here's the
thing I've done I've never done
something as stupid as as a rogue
exchange but the thing that I've done
every Christmas was you open gifts kids
are like I already have this like
grandma also got me this yeah well
where's the gift receipt we'll just take
it to Walmart where'd you get it doesn't
matter we'll just take it back to
Walmart all right you said this oh yeah
oh my goodness link so there's it but
you're the worst kind they don't require
receipts and if they carry it you just
you just return it there but but it's
okay
because they
I have some sort of accounting with the
manufacturer of the Oh
that's what you think question mark
that's what I've been telling myself I
mean if they'll take it they got maybe
they resell it
do they resell it Walmart holds the
inventory but they don't they don't they
don't carry the cost of the inventory
that's why they're so rich it's
something to do with that so my
rationale extends to their business
model that if I return some Fisher Price
and not on my learner's you know in
order to get a Nene Nandini's then
they're not or not on ours they just
they just say hey some jerk returned
this and you we got to do some
accounting here this is this is your
mix-up this is your product it's now
back on ourselves huh trying to cut
trying to I don't know at all I'm just
saying is that ethical
well who's wrong let's let's break this
down you've got the first store that you
let's say you bought it from a target
okay so you buy let's say grandma bought
it from a target grandma buys a widget
from a target yeah and she buys that
widget for $1 okay
so target gets $1 they give whatever
percentage to know they bought it
wholesale so they take the dollar so
target gets the dollar the widget
manufacturer has already made all his
money okay for that purchase here he
made his money when he sold to target to
target but not to Walmart so now you
take the widget back to Walmart which
should never go it wasn't it Walmart
Walmart also sells the widget Walmart
but I believe that then when the walmart
sells it again that the manufacturer
makes money again and so does Walmart
well hold on a second if so let's not
give it back to Walmart Walmart gives
you one dollar so you're at you are now
released from the transaction you paid
$1 and you gave it back
parties irrespective you don't have a
dollar anymore you're out of the
transaction whether it's ethical or not
we'll come back to that they pay no they
now they pay me 50 cents whatever
they're currently selling a thing at
because there's no receipt well let's
just say it's a dollar okay just say
it's the same price even though they say
they have the lowest prices let's say
99 cents so you get 99 cents you're out
you're out one cent Walmart takes widget
well I'm not out of one cent cuz grandma
paid it so and now Walmart pays a
basically has a restock the thing
because you open it up but they're gonna
pay money to have that restocked and
then they're gonna turn around and
they're gonna sell it again
[Music]
the restocking fee you placed the burden
of the restocking fee on Walmart and it
wasn't something that they had to
calculate it because they didn't sell it
to you in the first place it's unethical
but there's they now have inventory to
sell that they didn't have before so and
that makes up the difference I hope so I
don't know I don't know we could Google
it or we could just let you decide on
the other end of this how about we talk
about a woman who got super glued to a
toilet seat yeah let's go there
this isn't Kentucky this is June 2012
you know this one's really really simple
unidentified woman is in a Monticello
there apparently Oh Monticello there's a
Walmart inside of Thomas Jefferson's
house
no but there's a Monticello isn't
Monticello that's the Thomas Jefferson's
house yeah I know that that's a big wing
is that Monticello it's my dad cello
come to my come to my Walmart swing well
which I have designed but I don't
believe that Thomas Jefferson's home is
in Kentucky the garden area is on the on
the right side there yeah there's a
check out within the garden area you
don't it's this little secret checkout
area if you get some flowers even if
you've already gotten the order you can
check out there where there's not the
weight that you would experience at the
normal checkout counter Thomas Jabin
Thomas Jefferson speaking yes and this
is I'm giving you a tour of mine
Monticello Wal Mart I've designed and
this woman who is unidentified is heard
screaming loudly from a restroom stall
in June of 2012 paramedics show up well
they can't get her out of the bathroom
actually they can't get her off of the
toy
they realize that her Fanny has been
glued to the toilet seat her buttocks
because some prankster has placed
superglue all over the toilet seat and
they had to take the toilet have to
disconnect the toilet seat from the
toilet and she walks out of there I
don't know if they talked about a walk
of shame walking through that woman have
a toilet seat on her but walking all the
way across the water maybe we should
pants around your ankles No and a toilet
seat it glued to your butt what if she
has spandex she could have gotten to
spandex and pull them back over it you
know with regular yeah that woman should
be in a music video because her
badonkadonk isn't quite good but you're
shaped like a horseshoe the more I look
at it
horseshoe Heinie's she oughta she ought
to drive one of them motorized scooters
around or have her own website be
justified anyway
they couldn't figure out who had done it
but turns out pun intended
it turns out that this has happened six
times at Walmart to that woman she
should start raking the seat before she
sits down she should start getting she
should start putting one of those sheets
that they sell if you know is a reason
to put down the rest assured paper thing
oh that was that put a shout out to rest
assured the greatest name for a product
ever there's been six cases of this not
Wow
for this woman but at Walmart and I you
got a thing is this it was just a dude
who does this you know this is not a guy
who's comes I mean he got a girl who
came up with this idea this is a dude do
you know how to find the person who's
done this look around the exit to the
restroom because if you're not gonna
just hightail it out of there you're
gonna sit down somewhere nearby and
watch them exit with the toilet seat
stuck to there but I mean you there's
got to be a payoff for the prankster it
seems like like somebody who works at
Walmart who might might do this and your
sister and enjoys the whole thing as it
unfolds could be Sam Walton himself
but the guy who owns Walmart if the guy
is caught this could be second-degree
assault charges just so you know that
guy out there you're probably listening
to your biscuits you seem like a kind of
guy that would be into your biscuits I
just know that you've you ever get
caught we second-degree assault charges
oh well warning heated I'm not gonna
jump in on that one I got another one
February 2012 in a Walmart in Exton
Pennsylvania 32 year old dude named
verdun Lamont Taylor now this guy's
middle name is Lamont you know I've got
a special relationship with in with the
word Lamont because that's my fake last
name on my Twitter account it is because
if you're really interested in this back
when we made the Facebook song we
created Facebook profiles and I wanted
to create them before my character not
myself and I created one called link
LaMotte because the coolest guy and
grade school was Lamont mcclain and I
thought it was cool so I made it Lamont
my last name and it stuck with my my
Twitter handle too so there's that story
if you didn't know it but anyway this
dude kindred spirit I wouldn't have done
anything he didn't do I would have done
the same thing he would have done or I
don't know if I just said the same thing
twice or the opposite thing but you know
what about probably so
Burton Lamont Taylor decided can we call
him VLT VLT decides that he needs some
socks man and where do you go when you
need some socks or anything for that
matter in x10 Pennsylvania you go to the
wall mm-hmm
but he does something a little weird
just a little weird before going shock
sock shopping into Walmart he pulls up
into the parking lot and then proceeds
to strip down completely naked he takes
off everything I assume he didn't have
socks on but he took everything else off
and then he wanted a pure experience of
Walmart they didn't want to be tainted
but my clothes so he struts into the
Walmart and there's surveillance footage
I know I think I understand I think on
whereas mine was that because when
people do things like this I just I want
to know I want to understand their
motives I don't understand the the cow
guy yet but I think I get VLT okay name
a place another place I I know of a
place that supposedly had everything
that man could need why take anything in
when it's got everything you need is
that what you're getting it was a place
where man and woman were naked and
unashamed the Garden of Eden okay
he sees the Walmart like the Garden of
Eden link it's a place where a man
should just be able to be naked and
unashamed and get anything he wants well
that's not what he said
he's like the cradle of civilization he
didn't say anything but this is what he
looked like picture this guy he doesn't
look like how I picture Adam in the
Garden of Eden okay six foot four inches
tall he's not your height but he's
pretty tall 300 pounds that's the
biggest big guy VLT this dude naked as a
jaybird strutting down the parking lot
you watching all the surveillance
footage walks right in and I'm assuming
it isn't that like a bodybuilder
I'm not picturing VLT looking like a
bodybuilder VLT is just letting it all
hang out I got a low center of gravity
yeah well he walks in and he goes
straight for the customer service desk
course now that's where you make returns
but dude ain't got nothing to return I
mean if he's gonna buy anything where is
he keeping his wallet I don't want to
know he's looking for his mate man he's
looking for old he's looking for Eve
here here's the here's the here's the
funny thing um he goes to the customer
service desk and he there's a bag on the
counter they're telling me this is true
he reaches inside the bag okay in your
ear right now typing it into you right
now no there's they're telling me this
is actually true no this is from
Huffington Post and he reaches inside
the bag at the customer service test it
just happens to be there and what
we pull out Paris aha
what does he do put some on puts the
pair of socks on it could have just as
easily been like a pair of underwear but
it just happened to be yes - everyone's
chagrin and then he doesn't leave at
this point he's got what he came for he
doesn't pay for it
he just proceeds to peruse the Walmart
yeah when nothing but socks yeah this is
a great idea yeah I guess he didn't want
his feet to get dirty the right yeah you
know when's the last time they buffed
the floor I don't know if it's on real
dirty real fast I'll still pay for them
when I'm on my way out if I can ever
fish my wallet out of wherever it's
hiding yeah witnesses said they saw VLT
walking up and down the aisles
completely naked wearing sob I think
yeah I think you'd see that I think
unlike when I see amber yeah he's not a
streaker I think I'd stop and I think
I'd stop yeah I wouldn't and talk to him
well I don't know you know I'd say hey
man I would yeah I would not go in hand
with this everything okay we would be
two ships passing in the night
oh not I would not seek to spend some
quality time with this guy but he's not
a streaker as I was saying because he he
was just strutting as a stroller
he's a stroller yeah yeah streakers are
trying to get away fast yeah police were
called they arrived VLT was quote
hostile towards them really they had to
use a stun gun which is not good
when you're naked no no you don't want
to be stunned yeah when you're when all
you're wearing is socks is like if
you're if you belligerent towards the
police the last thing you can ask for
humbly is um could you please stone me
in the socks I could take it a little
better there they had to subdue him
because he spit on one of the office
yeah okay so you're saying this guy what
he wasn't right Ned he was arrested and
charged with indecent exposure
disorderly conduct simple assault
aggravated assault and misuse of socks
No
he also had to return the stop the socks
he didn't he was not allowed to leave
with the socks well that's unfortunate
he got nothing from this he's stunned
and drugged out and they like peel the
socks off of him and like put them back
in the bag before they look I'm sure
that VLT has made nothing but good
decisions since this left all of his
clothes in the car
yeah I gotta say I don't know if I can
top that
I've never gotten naked in a Walmart but
you have left something in the car I did
leave something in the car and you know
now that I'm thinking about it I realize
I don't know this is one of those things
were a thing my I don't think my
memories playing tricks on me I believe
that these two stories are connected I
believe Gambhir now know the battery
story I think that the reason I left I
did the quick exchange of the battery
now that I it makes a lot more sense in
my mind now that the MIT full memory is
coming back hmm
is what happened is it's justified
because I was a new father of Locke who
was like a couple of months old at the
time and he was in the back seat in the
car seat and I go to the Walmart and I
get out I go into the Walmart and I'm
going to exchange these batteries that's
exactly what I was doing I was going to
exchange the batteries and I get to the
battery section I'm looking I spot the
batteries and I grab the batteries that
I want now I'm gonna go to the exchange
and that is when it hits me I do not
have my son who I am responsible for
because he is in the vehicle whoo-hoo
now that is probably the worst
realization that any father can come to
know well one of them but now I listen
I'm gonna another one is I'm strolling
through the Walmart and nothing but
socks I'm gonna go and tell you right
now no laughing matter here that people
obviously do this lately there were kids
in her car and kids end up dying and
it's a horrible thing these people get
charged with
credible crimes and it's just a horrible
thing but every single time I hear one
of these stories and it's one of these
where it was just somebody totally
forgot I just you know my my heart goes
out for because you know they did what
they didn't it wasn't intentional but
thankfully in my situation it was
literally 90 seconds to two minutes
after I had been in a car like I'd been
in the Walmart and it was like a 55
degree day and he was asleep I know you
so it was just long enough to steal some
batteries yeah so just just just just to
explain things because it and I tell you
if you're a new if you're a new parent
especially a new dad because dads are
not nearly as attentive I'm generalizing
here not nearly as attentive as moms
most of the time you're a new dad you're
driving around and you're by yourself
and you've got your new baby in the back
your mind starts wandering you forget
you're at your father yeah you forget
that you're a dad
you're just single dude driving around
and you because your brain is so weird
the way it works sometimes and you get
to the Walmart night I'm in a Walmart
I'm gonna go in there and change my
batteries and then it takes two minutes
of being in the Walmart without your kid
to realize oh I'm a father and I'm
actually with my kid right now he's in a
car they just sprint it out that's well
no I make sure you got the right back on
the right batteries I put him in my
pocket and I put the other batteries up
and I did I do the exchange right there
one-for-one cuz you're there you might
as well get the right bag run out so
it's even worse yeah that's pretty good
I steal and then run out and I really
took a beat to make sure you had the
right one yeah you gotta get alright
batteries and then I run out and he's
totally asleep which is another reason I
forgot about him because you can make it
oversleep so anyway Walmart makes me
stupid man that's the conclusion here
well that is an elaborate justification
for stealing batteries I just have to
tell you so it wasn't as bad it wasn't
as stupid as I thought it was it was
actually stupider in one sense that I
left my kid in the car but it was not as
stupid in that it wasn't just a
convenience thing it was no I was
planning on doing the typical exchange
which later I would learn and it seems
obvious now that when you want to
exchange something into it
at a Walmart you go in and you give it
to a dude who puts a sticker on it when
you go in so what's in exchange yeah you
can't do what I did and have in your
pocket and go in and shop and then
exchange because then you could just
steal stuff yeah that didn't make sense
who's the dumb on so many levels but you
know I haven't been to a Walmart in
three years now really well no oh no
I've been to one and I've been to one in
North Carolina probably the past 18
months but I you know maybe I've moved
beyond it now maybe I'm maybe I'm
smarter I got two words that'll seen you
run it back in there what Mountain
Thunder Shh
imitation Mountain Dew he's in now what
it was called I think it's a purple
Thunder dr. Thunder dr. Thunder and
Mountain mist I can't remember anymore
I'm sure some of you are yelling it at
us right now but you know that I think
that we should just go hang out at
Walmart and I would I don't think I
would be a greeter I think I'd be a
sample giver which they don't really do
that that much it's not like Costco or
like Sam's right yeah but I would I
would gladly if they had a sample
position I think that would be the
coolest position at the Walmart because
you get to witness all these things that
we've talked about today and you also
get to be everybody sugar that hey you
know I'm a giving little pocket of
something to eat yeah it tastes so good
when it's this small you bought a whole
box and you're gonna be disappointed but
when you're hearing you're hungry and
your kids are crazy yeah I want to give
them something like um shut up I'm your
best friend I'm like I'm like a sample
clause sample club that's a good idea
yeah sample clause that's what I could
beat man and you might get to see a
naked fat dude with socks on and
potentially an ex-girlfriend and my
in-laws I will say that that's basically
what they do they don't give out samples
but they go to Walmart to see and be
seen you know in Kinston it's like well
we call us like what are you doing
Saturday night
well we're going to the Walmart and they
do call it Walmart with a k' and we saw
you when you saw Jimmy you can just pass
over that you have to explain that to
people because I do know inclination
that is do
but they they know it's Walmart the sign
is pretty big the T at the end is pretty
big but it comes out Walmart it just
comes out that way
yeah and I've asked and it's just home
there's no what you ask I asked you I
asked him you know it's Walmart right I
know but I just say it that way it just
comes out that way Walmart's Walmart and
sometimes it's got an S so why not why
not because what it caught what is
called as long as you can get there and
as long as you know money's still green
in the doctor thunder is still dark so
hotdogs are still red if you want to
hang out with us just go to your nearest
wall marks and we'll be hanging out
there we should do like a tour like we
did to those rest stops when we came out
to LA Walmart tour yeah I don't know
after this I mean after this podcast
that they'd be willing to do that will
be the guys in nothing but socks okay
let us know whether or not you enjoy
these your biscuits you know we do them
for you to enjoy I mean it is refreshing
our friendship but it's also for your
entertainment your you're just listening
pleasure
hashtag ear biscuits wherever hashtags
are accepted we'd love to hear from you
and you can count on us to be delivering
another podcast to your ears next Friday
[Music]
[Music]